could this be the start of a rekindled
romance for khloe kardashian i just want
to live my life and be happy chloe and
trey's songs were spotted together out
in los angeles on saturday night a
source tells e.t quote chloe and trey
songz were at the nice guy with a group
of people for a party hosted by justin
bieber they were sitting in a booth
talking one-on-one together during the
night but it appeared to be mostly
friendly the source goes on to say at
different points they were talking
closely to each other but it was also
because the music was loud the reality
star and bottoms up singer were quote
having fun and at one point she put her
hand on his shoulder while laughing
together the source also shares that the
good american founder and r b singer
quote left the party around the same
time yeah pretty much of course rumors
of chloe and trey's potential
relationship status are swirling on the
heels of all the drama that recently
unfolded with her on again and off again
boo and father to her three-year-old
daughter true tristan thompson after the
nba star admitted that he fathered a
child with marley nichols while he was
still with chloe in the latest trailer
for hulu's the kardashians we see coco
briefly reveal that she'll be addressing
the situation on the show tristan and i
are complicated
trust takes time
the 37 year old reality star also
weighed in on discussing the drama in a
new interview with variety saying quote
i wish i never had to talk about that
because it's not a fun thing to talk
about
but it is part of my journey in life so
we will see it on the show that's how it
should be when it comes to chloe's
dating life her sisters kim and kourtney
kardashian are trying to play matchmaker
a source tells e.t chloe's big sisters
are urging her to get back in the dating
pool turns out the beauty mogul and the
pooch founder who are both booed up at
the moment kim with pete davidson in
court with her fiance travis barker want
khloe to join them on double dates i
love it a source tells et that both kim
and court have guys in mind for chloe
kim a friend of pete's and courtney a
friend of travis's but get this chloe
does not want kim and courtney involved
in her love life and she has her reasons
the source says if the tv personality
gets set up she knows her sisters will
be sending group texts immediately about
it quote chloe wants it to be organic
and not have her whole family know a
play-by-play you just have to
deal with it it is what it is and then
there's the fact that they have very
different tastes than guys our source
adds is an inside joke between the three
sisters chloe says pete and travis are
so opposite from her usual type plus
she's enjoying being single our source
says she's quote happy by herself but
will start dating when she's ready we
all want to be cute over here okay
for now chloe is focusing on being a mom
to her daughter true thompson
[Music]
you